Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring our
polar opposite weekend.
We went to each pole of the earth.
Well, we both went on an adventure.
Yeah.
And the adventures couldn't
have been more different.
True.
And you know what?
We're both wearing coordinated
adventure outfits today.
We're both wearing camo.
Yeah, well camo sweats.
I gotta camo sweat on the inside.
Yeah, camo sweats
With a jacket over it.
on the outside.
And you've got black shirt
But
With a camo jacket
do you have
On the outside.
Polar opposite,
but it's the same.
Do you have that?
Do you have a lightening bolt?
I do not have a lightening bolt.
I win.
You probably paid forty more dollars
for that.
But look, hey look what
Kiko's got on.
Kiko's got on camo pants.
He's also got on
camo sweatpants.
Those look like
No, on a,
Mythical pants.
This isn't just the fact
that we've got camo on.
It's that we've all got camo sweats on.
Yeah.
That's different.
We're 'viving.
That's better.
If you don't have camo,
get the hell outta here.
Jacob, Jenna, Feldman.
I think Jacob's could be camo.
That's not camo.
If he were to go inside like a cave
where there was like paintings.
It's like a cave
painting shirt.
And then Jenna could be camo
if she went into like a denim factory.
She could then be camo.
I'm Canadian tuxedo.
I've got a Mythical shirt on.
And then Feld, well then you.
Okay, you're wearing
merch, so you can stay.
You can stay.
Yes, so we went on these adventures.
I went, um, on a camping adventure
that I would love to tell you about.
And what, you went on an adventure.
How would you describe
it as a polar opposite?
Um, it wasn't outdoors.
It was very, very indoors.
Tell the, tell the people.
Uh, I purchased a VR headset.
You know what?
I actually did?
I actually traveled the world,
but I never got outta my underwear .
And I am, ooo buddy,
I'm excited about this.
Now.
I brought it with me.
I have it.
You have it?
I put it on your head
and my head at some point.
I.
And what is it?
What's it called?
It's the Oculus Quest,
which is the standalone,
not a sponsor, standalone Oculus headset.
Now we played with the Oculus Rift
on GM More, I guess, before.
Mmhmm, yeah.
But that's the one that
has to be hooked up
to a, like some sort of PC or whatever.
Every time they hook me up to that thing
on Good Mythical More,
it's just to scare the crap outta me.
Yeah, and what, and you know what?
I'll talk more about that,
about how I feel like
my experience differed
from my previous experience
with VR and also.
I need a positive
VR experience.
This one,
I don't know if I'm gonna give you that,
but I'm not gonna give you any wires.
That's one positive.
I'm gonna just give you no wires.
It's all right here.
It's just, boop, all one thing.
And I think I've changed my life
and changed my family's life.
Uh, so I'll talk about that.
Um, you know it's, I woke up this morning.
The reason why I put on camo
is because it's finally
getting at least cooler here.
You know, if I get up
early to go to the gym.
Camo, cool?
I something.
It's not to make you cooler.
It's to make you not be seen.
Do I need to
Well
explain camo?
This is sweats, though.
Like wearing a layer of sweats.
Well you just don't have on sweats.
You have on sweats and a jacket,
which by the way, we went out
on a double date the other night,
uh, with our wives and, you know,
it had been a little bit
cooler than it has been.
It was like 66 degrees.
Well.
Link shows up at my house.
He has on a shirt, a sweater,
and then a jacket over the sweater.
Oh yeah.
It's like what in, what is wrong with you?
And I got my bandana in
my, in my jacket pocket
in case I need to really get my neck warm.
It, I,
when we went down to
It may have gotten down
to 63 degrees.
We went down to a place called "Eataly"
where all these different
markets and places
that there, it's all Italian food.
And Christy and I love Italian food.
And you and Christy love novelty foods.
And, and they
Novelty foods.
And you had been, you had
scoped this place out.
You told her about it in passing
and then she never forgot about it.
She's like we gotta go to this place.
And I thought since it was, I mean,
I thought it, it was on the west side.
And I'm like, ooo, once you
go, once you leave the valley,
it's liable to get cold
over there, ocean breeze.
I gotta be prepped, man.
Well.
I coulda left it in
You're not wrong.
The car.
I coulda let the sweater in the car.
It was hot.
It was too hot.
I mean,
You could have gone to like, Oregon,
the way that you were dressed.
I, I just, you know, it just felt,
it just felt inappropriate.
But I, I'm ready for it to get cold, man,
'cause I'm gearin' up for it, you know?
It's like, speaking of gearing up.
You know, it's the middle of October.
Oh, we.
We're about to do the
Bleak Creek Conversation.
We got some stuff comin' up.
At least we're traveling to places.
I mean, Boston.
That's gonna be cold.
This is,
this is my sly promotion of
Bleak Creek Conversations
in the midst of conversation.
Yeah.
I mean it's gonna be cold in Boston,
New York City, Chicago.
I don't think it's gonna be cold
in Dallas or Winston-Salem,
and then we're gonna
be back in Los Angeles.
Yeah, you're, this kinda fell apart there
as we moved into the warmer regions.
But yes, those are the
Bleak Creek Conversations.
We'll be talkin' about the book.
You get a book just by getting a ticket
and, uh, we're gonna premier
the documentary there
that we shot in Buies Creek
and the Los Angeles
show is going to feature
all your favorite Mythical crew members
if you wanna, uh, glad hand some of them.
When you're comin' out to Dallas,
wear, wear your Halloween costume.
I'm only using the term glad hand
because I know that you
like using the word,
so I just was tryin' to throw you a bone.
Now that you started usin' it,
I don't even think I use it any more.
Oh, you stopped.
But I just, I think fall,
like the precipice of fall
is my favorite time of year,
just 'cause I love jackets.
Yeah, I hear ya.
You know, and I like layers, man.
Well, I've noticed both of these things.
I love it.
And that's what's gonna make
the Bleak Creek Conversations
more special, is my layers.
How many layers you gonna bring on stage?
Uh, maybe three, four maybe.
Uh, we've also got the
Rhett and Link Live,
four more shows coming up in November.
If you wanna see us, this is the time.
Guys, we're tired of traveling.
You know what?
We're, we're gonna, I,
and now that I got this VR headset,
I'm not gonna leave my home.
So in 2020, it's, you ain't
gonna get a chance to see us.
Uh, and so if you wanna see us,
come to one of these shows.
Um.
Rhett and Link live dot com.
So to get into my camping excursion,
we, we did two nights camping
in Sequoia National Forest.
Um, you know, things have just gotten
so busy for us over the years.
We used to go camping.
We used to go off-roading.
We used to do things.
With a.
And a lot of times, with our friend Nick.
And, so Nick texted me,
and he was like, hey, um,
Allison, his wife's out of town.
He's taking his girls camping.
Um, and they're pretty young.
I'm not good at estimating ages.
Uh, how old are they?
They're probably five and seven.
Maybe eight.
I'd say seven and four.
Yeah, they're, 'cause Lando's only nine.
And, you know, we only
had this one weekend
but it kinda worked out
perfect that it was open.
I mean, when your kids get to be 16 and 14
and 15 like Locke is,
they start makin' all these plans
and they don't even tell you until,
so hey I need you to take me to so-and-so
or I'm doing so-and-so
or all my friends are comin' over
and it's like, I mean my
weekend is just planned
because I just have to be around
to make sure they don't
do somethin' stupid.
Right.
But lo and behold.
Guardian.
This week, guardian, this
weekend there wasn't anything.
And I really wanted to go camping.
I really wanted, I was pining
to take them camping, ha.
That's good.
Um, I felt sure they
wouldn't be up for it,
but I was like hey, you wanna go camping?
And they got that look on their face
they get whenever I mention
the word camping and hiking
or just anything involving
activity outdoors,
or not a screen.
Um, but then I said with
Nick's girls, Avonlee and Aria.
And, they all lit up.
And they're like, yeah.
And I was like, whoa this is great.
Yeah, let's do this.
So we went, we went camping with them.
And, um, on our way in,
something, one main thing happened
that I wanna tell you about.
But just as a preamble,
um, of course all over
the State of California,
they've got these fire towers
that have been built as
like lookout locations
from like high vantage
points in mountains all over.
I'm sure this is not
limited to California,
but it's very important here,
especially with the fires and whatnot.
And, you know, you stand up
on this really tall tower,
and you look out to see if
there's a sign of a fire
and it's kinda like the
opposite of Lord of the Rings
where somebody would light a fire
and then oh, you could see it
from the farthest mountaintop
and then you would light your fire
and then the next mountaintop
at the horizon would see it.
Signaling system.
It was a very efficient
long-distance signaling system.
Um, they have a signaling
system for when they see fire
because the fire needs to go out.
I'm drawing a comparison, but
it's probably way different,
maybe the opposite.
Um, they don't use them
that much any more,
so it turns out, um, Nick had this idea
to go see a few of them
and we, on the way in,
we went to the first one.
I wonder why that is, though.
I think because of
helicopters and different ways
that they surveyal.
Drones?
Perhaps.
I can't say, but I do know
that they don't use many of
the fire towers any more.
Um, some of them have
been burned by fires.
Yep.
You know?
Well, that's sad.
It makes sense.
Yeah, it's made out of flammable material.
Well, you put a tower in place
that there might be fires,
eventually it's gonna burn down.
Well, that's the spirit.
Um, so we get to this tower,
and there's a car parked there
because someone has rented the fire tower
to camp in it.
How freakin' cool is this?
Now that sounds like
somethin' I'd be into.
So we look up there.
I mean, this thing is freakin' tall, man.
And.
How many feet?
Oh, gosh, are you tryin'
to make me look stupid?
No, just give me an estimate.
Uh, well I'm six feet tall.
Oh gosh.
That's not a good place to start.
Yeah, I can't eye a tower
and know how tall it is.
Well is it a thousand feet tall?
35 feet.
Or is a hundred feet tall?
It's 35 feet tall?
So that it's just tall as
like jumping off the cliff
at Lake Acapulco?
Yeah, it might be a
little taller than that.
I don't think it's 50 feet.
It's gotta be taller
than 35
It's not 50 feet.
Well, I'll show them a
picture in the video version.
How many steps did you go up to get to it?
I didn't count the steps
because the girls
How many full flights
of stairs did you go up?
It was one really straight flight,
a long ways up.
What, it never, there was no switch backs?
No switch backs.
It was .
Straight up, very steep too.
And they were.
Weird.
They were like poured concrete steps,
very, very steep.
Um, we were able to go up there
because the two women who
were camping up there,
right when we got there,
Nick was like, hey can we come up?
They were like, uh, sure.
So we go up there.
Um, two women and a dog up there.
We start lookin' around.
This place is surrounded
by
Sounds like a sitcom.
Surrounded by glass.
Just filing away ideas over here.
You have to go on the website
exactly six months in advance
of when you wanna book this place
and like it's like you gotta be on,
it's like gettin' tickets.
High demand.
It's like gettin' tickets to see
Billy Eyelash.
You know, you gotta be all over it.
Right.
Oh my gosh, it's sellin' out.
Mmhmm.
And, um, that's how it is
with a lot of these camping places.
But it's pretty cool.
It's very windy up there.
Of course a great view.
You know you're gonna get
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
a good view in a fire tower.
You're above the trees, right?
Above, above everything.
You're on a mountaintop.
Then on a tower top.
That's why it doesn't
have to be super tall.
Which is at least 75 feet
in the air.
It doesn't have to be.
That makes more sense.
I've been picturing, like
a long stretch of trees
and then just like a giant
tower that's looking over 'em,
but yeah, makes sense.
It's on a mountain.
You gotta be careful comin' down.
And if you gotta use the bathroom
it's a long way to go down
to get to that outhouse down there.
Oh, there's no, like tube or anything
up there on the top?
No.
And they had a pulley system
to pull up all their crap.
Oh surely you can just pee off the side.
So that was pretty cool.
I mean, we just camped on the ground.
And then we go to the
Trail of a Hundred Giants
where they don't have 100 sequoia trees
but there's a lot of
sequoia trees growing.
You and I went there with Mike,
probably seven years ago.
Five.
Five years ago.
And it's a very accessible path.
If you're, if you're thinking
about going in that area,
I definitely recommend going
to the Trail of a Hundred Giants
'cause you get to see all
these sequoia trees up close
and even if you're not great at hiking,
it's right off the road.
Right.
You may remember when we went
that a double sequoia grouping had fallen.
Like there's two sequoias
that grew basically
right beside each other
and, I mean, these are
the largest living things
on the planet by mass.
Like, more massive than a
blue whale, the sequoia trees.
So, and pictures don't do it justice
but it is amazing just to be there.
I mean, seeing the redwoods is awesome.
Redwoods are taller
but sequoias
are fatter.
Are fatter, bigger around and stumpy.
Still freakin' huge and tall.
Um, you may remember that
two of them fell at once.
And one of 'em.
across a path.
Somebody caught one on.
There is a YouTube
another one.
There's a YouTube video,
They don't fall very often.
They're in the winter of um, some falling.
Of one being caught falling,
which is crazy.
I mean if one of the
largest things on the planet
is falling and you're there for it.
Well not just that.
You're gonna pull out your
phone and record that stuff?
It's the fact, they're what?
They're.
What are you a frickin'
war journalist?
They're like a thousand
years old or something,
so the chances of you catching it falling,
I mean, it's just very very slim chance,
but I guess people are
always there walking.
Well not in the winter,
not when it's like really snowed in.
They tend to fall under
the weight of the snow.
But when we went in the summertime,
they had started to rebuild the path
that the sequoias had fallen across,
so that now you could,
and we climbed on it .
They leave, yeah, of course
they leave it all there
'cause it's amazing to
be able to walk on it.
Yeah, they don't really,
I don't know that they
want you to walk on it.
They built the path around it.
Oh, they didn't build the path through it?
Like a tunnel?
No, um
Missed opportunity.
Call me next time.
Well, update since we've been.
Another huge sequoia tree
fell this past winter.
What's happening?
And it fell
Mites?
They said it was from
the weight of the snow.
You know, we had a lot
of snow last winter.
It fell.
Not only did it fall, it fell diagonally
across the two that you and I saw.
Oh, it's like we're starting a,
like a Lincoln log situation.
Yeah, they're stackin' up.
They're building themselves
the largest cabin.
Ever.
So we are,
so that whole part is closed down.
You can't walk over there,
except for the fact that
everybody still walks over there.
And climbs on all of it.
So we're climbing on like
these three sequoia trees
that are basically stacked on each other.
I mean, when it's laying on its side,
it's still like eight feet tall.
Yeah, they're big.
So you're having to
climb up on this thing.
So I'm climbing up there,
and Lily and Lincoln are in
front of me at this point.
And I just see Lily who's standing.
As I'm climbing up, she's
standing looking down.
She's like oh no, oh no.
There's no way.
I can't believe this.
And she's staring down.
And she says, "My phone
fell out of my pants."
She was wearin', she was
wearing some sweatpants,
not unlike the ones that
Kiko got from Mythical.com.
Dude, you gotta be careful hikin'
and doin' activities with
your electronics in a pocket
of a sweat pant.
Right.
And of course, I'm immediately like,
wanting to go into dad lecture mode.
But then I thought, you know what?
This is the moment that
heroes are made of.
'Cause she looked down and I get up there
and I, before I even saw where
the phone was or whatever,
I was just okay, it fell down there.
We'll go get it.
I'll get it.
How big is this hole?
Be the hero.
But then I got up there and I looked
and it had fallen.
It had bounced Plinko style
in between the stack
of three sequoia trees
down into a hole.
And the hole was, um, no, I could put my,
I could put my head
and one arm through it.
Like it was about that big around.
That's all it was.
How far were you from the hole?
You had to go down into it.
So, I crawled down and was like listen,
let's not panic.
She was like, "Dad, it went in that hole."
Like.
Probably like 700 phones in there.
There's somethin' about,
I just have this belief whenever
you're losing something.
It's like if you believe
that you can find it,
it drastically increases the
chances that you will find it.
Like, because if you
don't actually believe
you could find it,
but you still look,
it's really, you're just kind
of half-ass looking, you know?
Like, subconsciously,
you know you're just
going through the motions
just to say you did.
Yeah.
And I believe this.
This is one of my deeply
held beliefs, Rhett.
How many deeply held beliefs do you have,
if this is one of them?
Probably,
probably this and like
that layering is good.
When in doubt, layer out.
There's not a lot.
Yeah, those are my main ones.
So I Get down on my belly.
I crawled down over the first tree
and then lay down on the second tree,
the older tree that had fallen,
and then I look in this hole
and then when I look in the hole
and I'm, I'm holding on to my phone,
putting it all the way into the hole
with the flashlight on.
Risky business.
And I'm looking down.
I'm like, I could freakin'.
I had a vice grip on this thing.
The shakiest man in the world
is holding his phone over a phone hole.
I'm like.
A phone hole.
And I'm like, I cannot lose my phone.
That would make me really angry.
So far, I just find this amusing
and a good occasion just
to lecture my daughter
when it's over.
Yep.
And I look down in there
and it splits into two holes.
Oh gosh.
And there's sawdust and
sprinkles and shards
and all types of sequoia
carnage down in there.
Sawdust, so somebody was
tryin' cut a hole through 'em.
No, I just think the
more people walked on it,
the more debris went down
in the hole.
Oh, okay.
And Lily, I said Lily you go down.
She goes down below the second set
and she's, I can hear
her but I can't see her.
And we're at opposite ends of, like
different accesses to this hole.
And I'm thinkin'
if these things shift,
we're gonna get crushed
by a frickin' sequoia,
the largest thing on the
plant's gonna smush me
and my daughter.
It'll be worth it, though.
But we gotta find this phone
because that's all that matters.
Right.
Did you ever,
did you ever say
She.
I will find it.
I will find you.
Did you ever say that?
No, I didn't say anything.
Because you believed it so deeply, though.
Thought maybe you woulda done that.
Okay.
So I'm lookin' down in there.
I'm pulling debris out.
And I'm like, if it went
into this hole to the right,
you're never seein' it again,
'cause the hole to the left,
it sounds like it's closer to to you.
And then Lily's like, I can.
She starts crawling in there.
And I'm gettin' really nervous
that she's gonna get crushed.
Well if they haven't shifted yet,
I don't think that a
couple of people on them
is gonna cause 'em to shift.
At some point, everything shifts.
Yeah, but what are the chances though?
Its worth it.
And you need your phone.
You got your contacts in there.
Um, Lily had been in kind of a grumpy mood
before this.
She a
She's a teenager.
You know.
You chalk it up to that.
Teenagers and big trees, they don't mix.
Or hikin'.
Yeah.
She's like
I got it.
I'm like what?
You got it?
She's like, "I got it."
And it's like
I stood up.
She comes out from under
these sequoia trees.
She's like, "I have it."
"I have it."
And she was, it was
like, it was so worth it.
Yeah.
Like that's the key to
making teenagers happy.
Take something they love,
then make 'em find it.
Get, let 'em have a near
phone-death experience.
She was exasperated.
I mean, she rode this emotional wave
for the next 17 minutes.
Oh.
It was amazing.
I even vlogged about it.
I missed that.
I didn't post anywhere.
Oh.
I'll post it on the video version of this.
Okay, so Lily just found her phone.
Let me see it.
You got it?
Prove that you got it.
So we were walking up here
where this fine young man is.
Don't drop your phone.
You see how you got
your phone in your hand?
Don't drop it
because it will go down into that hole
which is underneath a fallen sequoia tree,
giant sequoia
and then you're gonna have to get down
and look for it.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe she found it.
I was like,
I was so relieved.
It's like it feels so
good to find something.
You know that time that
like we went boating
and then Chris threw his, like some,
who threw the keys?
And they went in the water
and then we were, he was, I was like
you can find 'em.
And he waded out into the water.
As I recall it,
you threw the keys
and they went low and they
hit the side of the boat
and dropped directly into the lake.
And then the boat drifted
And without hesitation,
like Chris dove down
and came up with the keys
which never happens.
Crazy.
Never happens.
If you drop keys in a lake,
you're, they're always lost.
I think that's the root of my faith
Oh, you should
in the believing
you can find something.
You should tell Chris that.
Yeah, Chris formed the bedrock
of my faith in finding things.
And that's why I found that
skittle on LTAT so quickly.
Here it is, right here.
Isn't that an M&M?
'Cause I believed I could find it.
I think you found it because
you were closest to it.
But I mean, I
I believed I could find it.
Okay.
And I did find it.
So there's not really
any arguing with that.
I found it very quickly.
You did.
1600 M&M's, I found the
Skittle in 20 seconds.
Belief, man.
It's a beautiful armor.
Beautiful armor.
Makes for the heavies sword.
Like
Punchin' underwater.
You never can hit what you're aimin' for.
I don't think he says aiming.
Uh, there it is.
Yeah, these 41-year-old white boys
know some John Mayer.
Nothin' like, Lily knows
some John Mayer, too.
Um, yeah.
Felt good, man.
It felt good to be in the
outdoors finding a phone,
maintaining a lifeline.
I'm proud of you.
But teetering on the edge
of being isolated from an electronic.
Well, ironically, your entire, I will say.
I must point out
that your entire story
about camping and being in the outdoors
centers around you recovering
an electronic device.
It does, doesn't it?
Which I think is a great lead in to,
I just didn't go camping at all.
I just found the electronic device
and enjoyed it for the weekend.
We'll talk about that.
But first, we do wanna let you know
that we got some new designs
that just dropped.
Mythical dot com.
I mean we got, I don't know.
There's like seven new t-shirt designs?
Is this the largest drop ever?
We're gonna say no, it's
not the largest drop ever
but it is amongst the largest drops ever.
Seven new shirts
that ironically we are
not wearing right now.
Because they're too awesome
to wear on a podcast.
I don't think we have them yet.
Check out everything at mythical dot com
because rep your boys.
Feel good, you can feel good
knowing that what you're wearing
makes our lives possible.
Sends us on trips, camping.
Yeah.
Gas money.
Yeah, but then you're responsible.
I mean if you were a
wasteful, wasteful dude,
and your daughter drops her phone
and you're like screw it.
We'll get another one.
You know, but you didn't say that.
You said, I gotta be,
I've got to be a good steward.
I'm gonna find this phone
even if it means sacrificing the lives
of me and my family,
I'm gonna find this phone
because I'm a responsible, frugal man.
I was not the hero 'cause
she found the phone.
Yeah, but you know,
That's the part that sucks.
it was your deeply held belief
that led her to find the phone.
Because she had given up.
It was obvious in the tone of her voice.
In the vlog?
Yeah.
That you didn't see.
Mythical dot com, check it out.
Okay, Rhett, let us have this VR thing.
You didn't tell me you were getting this.
This is
Well, it was
spur of the moment.
This, oh.
It was an impulse buy,
which I haven't done in a while.
Good gosh, I gotta take off my jacket.
Yeah, why don't you de-layer.
Since we're
It's gettin' warm in here.
Actually in shelter.
We're actually in air
conditioned shelter right now.
Gettin' hot in here.
You could be naked and be comfortable
in this particular room, um.
Whew.
Uh, so this is how this happened.
Uh, I was listening to a podcast
and the guy who, I think he,
he's like a video game guy.
I don't, I can't remember his name
who's currently heading up,
or at least intimately involved
with this Oculus Quest program.
This is how out of the loop I am
when it comes to this stuff.
I didn't even know that
this thing existed.
It's been out since the spring.
Okay.
And if you're any sort of
follower of this type of thing,
you already knew this.
But I'll hold it up or you, Link.
Hold it up for me.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, so it basically looks like
This is it.
An ocular
This is the whole system.
There are
no cords.
Uh, it's a true standalone system,
which it's not the only standalone system
but it is the best standalone system
as far as I can tell
based on what the research that I've done
because most of the reviews
said that for the uninitiated,
if you were, unless you
were playing a game on this
and then playing it side by side
with something on the Rift,
which uses PC power,
you wouldn't really know
Oh really?
The difference.
It's not like there's like a latency issue
or anything like that.
Some of the things that play VR.
Now the resolution I think
is a little bit lower.
But depending on what the
game that you're playing,
the resolution, you quickly adjust.
You quickly adjust to,
you know, the resolution,
which is, you know, not great
but it'll definitely
get better in the future
but it's more than adequate.
So, he's talkin' about this thing
and, by the way, I see
that you're smelling that.
This is washable guard that I got
that you change out,
'cause you know, I got my kids'
faces goin' in this thing.
Have you washed it?
My kids.
My kids stick their faces in so many.
So this actually, this cover
was just installed this week,
so Shepherd has worn this a little bit
and I've worn it a little bit
but that's it.
But just like once or twice.
I don't know exactly what,
I don't know what over,
what came over me in order
to make this purchase.
But he was just talking about it
and it just hit me.
When they began talking about,
this is really a turning point for VR
now that the systems are standalone
and you don't need a PC or console.
You could wear this on a bus.
It felt like a prescription for me.
It was like, oh this is a
turning point for you, Rhett.
This is when you, this is when you,
a guy who doesn't wanna have a PC at home
and hook it all up and have wires.
We don't even have a place for that.
Yeah.
This is when you can get in this game.
'Cause you, you've been
wishing you were on the inside
for a while.
I just like feeling like I'm
on the cutting edge, man.
Even though I'm not,
as is evidenced by the fact
that I didn't even know this existed.
I don't like go to CES
and stuff like that.
But I just like the idea of feeling like.
One of my deeply held beliefs
is the idea of feeling like
I'm on the cutting edge.
Okay.
How quickly did you get it
because you wanna be.
Same day.
What, really?
Welcome to America, man, 2019.
You got it the same day?
I ordered this thing
'Cause I was gonna say
On Amazon
You could wear off.
And it came the same frickin' day.
Like it's such a reward
for an impulse buyer
where you can get something
delivered to your door
the day you make a decision to buy it.
Did they know you were
gonna order it or something?
I just think that they.
Was he out there just
waitin' for his ding to ding?
Ding, ding, ding.
I don't know
how the ding dings work, but
uh, I just know I got it.
I got it on a Friday night.
So.
And then everything else stopped, huh?
This is the Friday night
that I was camping.
Yeah, put that in perspective.
So, to give you an idea
of how this all went down,
now I've got some VR experience,
having played on Good
Mythical More, along with you,
and because I, I feel like
you're getting distracted.
I'm listening.
You can't think about two things at once.
So don't, just pay attention.
I'm gonna hold this over here.
Um, I feel like every previous experience,
now the experience we had at
Sundance a couple years ago
and we went into this, we went into that,
we did the VR and we were
like walking on the plank
and we were working with each other.
Full body.
Um,
Tactics.
That was pretty amazing.
I mean
That was crazy.
Weren't doing it for,
we were kinda thinking
about the fact that these
people were watching us
and so we're still trying
to play it up like we do,
but obviously when we do
it on Good Mythical More,
I know that I'm on a show
so I never forget that I'm on a show
and so my brain is focused
in two different places,
inside the headset
and the world that is
being broadcast to me,
but also the world that
is being broadcast to you.
You know you're being watched.
And so it changes the experience
and I didn't really have
a mind blowing experience.
It didn't feel like a
pivotal thing for me.
Because I haven't, you know,
We've got it
At Sundance or at More?
In More.
Okay.
We have an Oculus Rift here.
Have I ever said hey I'm comin' in
for the weekend to play it?
No.
Have I ever asked anybody here,
can I get on the Rift?
No.
So why would I buy something
to have at the house?
Because I can have it at the house.
Because I can make it
my own personal thing.
There's no wires.
Now,
So what does it do?
Do you remember, what does it do?
I mean what
You know what it,
did you do on it?
You know what it does.
So do you remember, um,
I don't, did you get a Nintendo
right when they came out?
I got one for Christmas,
when they were selling
'em with the power pads,
but I did not get the power pad.
I have to think it was
around that same time.
I don't remember not having one.
Well.
Like when everyone
was talking about it.
I think Nintendo came out in '87
and I don't know if it was
Christmas of '87 or '88
when we like when
I think it
We at Buies Creek got word.
I think it was '86 actually.
'86, okay, so the next year,
it must have been Christmas of '87,
'cause there's no way that we were that
on top of the trends.
No.
But, so by the time Nintendo
was being sold at Brendle's,
like when my parents
Yeah.
Were in the game,
and we had an Atari,
and I played Atari.
Yeah, sure, I played some.
Yeah.
But I specifically remember sitting down
and playing Super Mario Brothers in 1987
and feeling like something had shifted,
that my life was going to be different.
And I remember, um going to bed that night
and thinking about Super Mario Brothers,
like it was the line
between reality and dreams
had been disintegrated.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It was like,
it was.
It's interesting.
For me, I remember getting that feeling
when I first got cable
and I watched Nickelodeon,
like I couldn't stop thinking about
what else I was going to
get to watch on Nickelodeon.
But I didn't have
That's an
interesting take.
But I didn't have
that reaction to video games.
Well, you know.
Finally programming just for me.
That's always on.
Yeah, you know
just think.
I'm missing something.
It's difficult to emphasize
just how different it felt
and how big of a leap it felt like.
Now, that was pretty much,
that was the biggest leap for me,
and then I never got Super Nintendo.
We got a Sega Genesis around,
like a year later or whatever.
Those are really the
only two gaming systems
that I ever had.
I didn't, my life changed and I got busy
with sports and stuff
and then we just never
ended up having consoles.
I just wasn't a video games guy.
And of course I haven't been as an adult.
But putting this on,
and I was playing the game, the two games
that I downloaded were Beat Saber
which is one that everybody says
you gotta have, you gotta have it.
It's and essential game on the Quest
which is essentially
Dance, Dance Revolution
with the light saber.
You're basically sitting
there with two sabers, yes,
and you're chopping the
saber, chopping these blocks,
red and blue block, depending
on which side it's on,
to a beat.
And you're doing it in all different ways
and you're dodging things and whatever.
Pretty awesome.
But I also downloaded
a game called Superhot.
Now it sounds like it might be a little
Racy.
It's not
A little slinky dinky.
Uh, it has nothing to do
with dinkies or slinkies.
It is a, it's a game that's
been out for a while,
a console, it's been on consoles.
I guess it's been on PC's as well.
But essentially it is a
first-person shooter game
where you are, um, your motion
determines the speed at which time moves.
So if you get, if you stand
still, you're not moving,
time stands still.
And in every level,
there's an array of like
weapons in front of you
that are all kinds of different things,
things you can throw or
things you can shoot.
And there are these completely red dudes.
Mmmhmm.
Almost look like they're
made out of red glass,
who are coming at you and
shooting things at you.
Okay.
They're trying to kill you.
And multiple ones coming at you.
And you have to stop them,
but they'll shoot like a bullet at you
and it's coming at you
and you can see it coming.
You can stop.
You can see where it's going.
And you can move out of the way,
but you gotta make sure you
don't move into another bullet
or whatever.
So if you freeze,
the bullet freezes.
Everything freezes.
Time moves as fast as you do.
Now,
So it's kinda like
the matrix.
You're going
to experience it in a second.
Just be forewarned.
Like when the, when time would slow down
and he would like do a back bend
and the bullets would fly over him.
Exactly, same thing.
Okay.
So I'm playing this
game in my living room,
and basically it gives you the opportunity
to mark off a playing space.
And we like moved the, I moved the
Coffee table?
Coffee table out of the way.
I made a giant, like a 10 by 12 space,
which is pretty big for VR.
Okay.
And
Right next to a pool?
No, I was inside.
Good.
And so then I'm playing this game
and I'm just having,
I'm having that feeling
that I haven't had since 1987.
Oh yeah?
I'm like this changes things, man.
Were you cry, were you tearin' up?
No, I probably looked like an idiot.
I was in my underwear in my living room
with a headset on,
dodging invisible bullets.
Now, no shirt?
Are you talkin' like under t-shirt?
No shirt, man.
I don't sleep with a shirt on.
Boxers?
Yeah.
Or briefs?
Not briefs, boxers.
Okay, boxer briefs?
Possibly?
Why do you care?
Because this is disturbing to me
and I wanna make sure I've got it right.
'Cause if there's an opportunity for me
to be less disturbed,
okay, there was a shirt and wear boxers,
I feel better.
So I play
and then I do a couple other things.
I also got a game
called
You're dodging bullets
like Matrix, like you're
doing a back thing.
Well, you don't, I'm not hurting.
I'm not gonna hurt myself.
You're doing Tai Chi basically.
You're slow motion.
That would be a, we'll see
how it looks in a second.
I'll do it first to demonstrate
and then let you get in on it.
I also did something called,
there's a, not a game,
but an app called Wander.
Okay.
And this basically is every single thing
that has been mapped with Google maps
on the, like Google street view basically
in the entire world
you have access to it,
and you can enter into it.
So you can say go to my
old address in Fuquay
where I used to live
and you'll be at, you'll be on the street
at your old house.
And you can see full 360 view,
'cause that's the, 'cause the 360 camera
captured all this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you can also go to
like amazing locations
that they've mapped around the world.
I went to the freakin'
island that we were,
the Fiji, when we went to
Castaway Island in Fiji.
Oh, yeah?
And it's voice activated.
You say, "Go to Castaway Island, Fiji."
And all of a sudden, you're
on the freakin' beach
at the resort that we stayed at.
What?
You could go to the Trail of 100 Giants.
Probably walk it.
I don't know, some people
have mapped this stuff
and it's like user generated,
like I think it, you probably have to have
some sort of special
application or whatever
but you can go to a remote location
and then send it into the system.
I don't know how.
It's a crowd-sourced kind of thing.
Anyway, that was super cool.
But I, I'd still done
all this
Did you knock on the door?
You can't do that yet.
And so I did all this
and I'm doing this by myself.
I haven't, my kids haven't
even done this yet.
'Cause I'm like dad's
gonna figure this stuff out
for you guys.
Which is code for this is my toy.
And you'll never get it.
Yeah, and I also
did say that.
I was like this is going in my room
'cause I want it to be cared for
and you can use it at my discretion.
Oh yeah.
Also I don't want the kids
to like get addicted
because, case en pointe,
so I put the thing onLocke
and the only thing,
so there's a first,
it's called first steps.
And it's basically an orientation
to how everything works.
And so you've got these
controllers, you know,
that have a few functions on them,
like there's a grip and there's a trigger
and there's this thing.
Mmhmm.
Basically they replicate
pointing and gripping
and all kinds of hand motions
with this simple controller.
And in the orientation,
you're in this room.
Now, just first of all,
just when the room and the world
is sort of generated around you,
and then like this like desk
comes up in front of you
and there's all these things on it
and you pick these things up
and it's showing you how
to interact with things
by telling you what buttons to press.
And there's like a rocket thing
that you pull a string
and then it flies away
and then you're actually,
there's a drone like
inside the orientation
and you're controlling
it with a fake controller
that you're holding
but you're holding a controller
in VR controlling a thing
but you're just using.
So, it's pretty mind blowing.
So the best way to
introduce somebody to it,
which I'm gonna skip past that for you
because it takes too long.
You've also been in VR before.
Is to use this program, this first steps.
Yeah.
So I put the headset online.
It's kinda like brain mapping.
Yeah, you're adjusting to
how you're going to interact
with this world.
So I put the thing onLocke.
He's going through and he's
doing these little experiments.
And then he's standing there
in the middle of the living room
and he says, "Dad."
'Cause you feel like
you have to talk louder
because the people are outside
of the world, you know.
Dad, this
Are you there?
Dad, this is the best thing
that has ever happened to me.
Really?
And I felt like, that made me a proud dad.
I sent my son into VR
and he realized that that's
where all his dreams come true.
Oh, gosh.
He literally felt like
it was the best thing
that ever happened to him.
Well, to me that's what reminded me
of that Nintendo moment.
I was like this is his Nintendo moment.
Because he's a kid that,
he's a kid in 2019 in L.A. in a family
that can afford to get
him stuff like an X box.
Mmhmm.
This kid, you can't blow his mind.
You can't blow his mind.
He's a cynical teenager.
It blew his mind.
Now if he took this thing to 100 Giants,
and dropped it in a hole.
And found it.
That would be even better.
We might have to arrange that.
If he begins to take it for granted,
I'll definitely do that.
Same thing with Shepherd.
Shepherd was, had this incredible
time playing this thing.
So what I'll do.
It is mind blowing.
And you never get a second
chance to have that feeling,
that VR virginity.
Right, which you're
technically not a virgin.
Right, right.
It's like you, you've
experimented a little bit.
But, you know, you didn't
know what you were doing.
You were young.
Right, right.
I do need practice.
You're gonna get the real thing.
So what I'm gonna do,
is I'm going to set up,
I'm going to get into Superhot.
You're gonna, then I'm gonna stand up
and I'm gonna do just a little bit
and then I'm gonna get out of it.
You're gonna have to come over here
because I've got the guardian
kind of set on this side.
All right, but maybe,
maybe there's still, you know,
there's still some, pardon the euphemism,
there's a little cherry to pop.
I don't know.
Maybe this is still gonna
be a formative experience.
Okay, yeah, I'll avoid that language.
Okay.
So are you, are you gonna be whispering?
Or yelling?
Change guardian.
Wait, I'm gonna put the,
I wanna make sure the
mic is still near you,
but you got to speak up.
It, it captures better than you think.
Okay, uh, okay.
Now of course none of us
can see what's happening.
So.
Yeah, so you can get,
I'm gonna stand up.
What are you doing?
Loosening everything,
gettin' stretched out.
Okay.
You just waggling your hips a little bit.
Now that I've completely beat this game,
I can go into any,
there's all these discs
and I can put 'em in different computers
to access different levels.
Okay.
Oh, there's a frickin' light there, man.
I have to reach up here and grab this.
You coulda bust a light.
You've lost total, total contact
with the real world, man.
This is not healthy.
You're not really having
to move that much.
Yeah, well, it gets very,
it gets a lot more complicated
as it gets into the game.
You gotta start doing squats,
And now
Warrior poses and stuff.
Okay, here's what I'm gonna do, Link.
I'm gonna give this to you.
This is gonna be great.
There is a black ball in front of you
when you're gonna have this on
and you're gonna reach down
and you're gonna grab that
and that will start the action, okay?
Okay.
Now you're not gonna be mad at me are ya?
Yeah.
Okay.
So stand exactly where I was standing.
I'm gonna leave my glasses on.
Gosh, get it over my glasses.
Oh, yeah, there's a I'm in a white room.
Okay here you go.
Here's the left hand.
That's left hand, yep.
And right hand.
I got floaty hands.
I'll move back over here.
And then, okay.
Wup.
Be still.
Be still, you see those guys?
Oh yeah.
He's comin' at me.
So this dude up here shot me.
Do you have a gun?
No I have a hand.
Pick up a gun.
Oh he hit me in the shoulder and I died.
This is what I look
like in my living room.
All right, so then.
It's riveting.
Oh yeah, boom, boom.
Oh buck shot.
What, what did I just knock over?
It's the microphone.
God, oh.
Glad you got camo on.
I just, I just threw,
I just threw the gun at a guy.
And it killed him, right?
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
You don't have to say boom.
All right I'm frozen.
Nobody's movin'.
Whoom.
I killed that guy.
The sound effect's really good.
Oh, I just dodged a bullet.
I grabbed a gun and I shot him.
And he just died.
He's grabbing his gun.
Oh, he shot me.
Okay, all right.
Okay.
We can do this more later.
All right, oh.
My glasses.
Put the controllers down.
Oh, ah,
My heart rate is freakin'
through the roof, man.
Um, the one thing I gotta say
is it's just a white room of red guys.
There's not a lot of graphics happenin'.
Like Turbo Graphic 16
blows it out of the water.
I'll show you.
Whoo.
Even just the beginning.
My whole body was tense.
You can justify this as a workout.
Oh, easy.
Like my core was engaged.
Well.
I felt like I was in a squatting position
for most of the time.
And I learned how to kill people.
So like I'm like.
They're not really people.
I'm comfortable killing.
It's like robots.
Red robots.
Um, okay.
Whoo.
So that was, that was just a little taste.
Now one of the things that happened to me
after playing that game was.
Whew, gotta stretch.
It changed the way I was moving.
I was literally eating
cereal for breakfast.
You talkin' about the real world now.
Yeah, I was eating cereal for breakfast
and I found myself getting
ready to take a bite
and then stopping taking
a bite and looking around
and seeing if any red
men were coming after me.
And I was like.
And then I would eat the cereal.
I was, I thought I could,
I can make everyone else
slow down by stopping.
It's kinda like.
So the way that your brain adapts
'cause you're, the whole deal
is that your brain.
Everything in your brain
is telling you that you
This is how
this is how the world
are there.
This is now the world.
This is your world
and so you could train.
There's so many different
applications for it.
I'm sure people are already doing this.
But in the way that just
a couple of sessions
of playing that game,
I changed my actual
interaction in the real world.
If there was something
that I was struggling with,
you could definitely train somebody
to address some kind of problem in that.
Like a surgeon or an EMT simulator.
Would you buy like a super
realistic EMT simulator?
Because it, you know.
I'm sure there probably is such a thing.
You don't wanna roll up on an accident
and then be totally paralyzed, you know.
And they, when my mom was EMT certified,
I was in middle school
and I'd stroll through the room
where they were getting their training
and they'd be showin' some graphic images.
Right.
Of nasty.
Well, okay, so
But this is a step further.
You're right that the
graphics that you saw,
this ois one of the most
simple, simple graphic games
that there is now.
There's other games
that are much more vivid
and lots of different colors
and you know.
It's cool game play though.
One of the things I
also did with this was,
because I heard the guy talking about it.
He was like you know, not
everybody has great home theater
but this can basically
replicate a home theater.
So there's actually,
I've got Netflix on here.
So you are in, I gotta
show it to you, man.
You just wanna put it on and
see what Netflix looks like?
Yeah, yeah I wanna see Netflix.
I also wanna eat cereal in VR if that's
when you were referring to that earlier
I got excited.
But I totally know what
you're talking about
as you're getting ready,
that your brain starts to
think things in the real world
work that way,
like there's many times
when I'm looking at like a
brochure or something with fine print,
and I will find myself reaching down
to then zoom in on it.
You know like, oh let me make that bigger.
And at least the thought
will cross my mind
and then I'll realize oh
no this is, can't happen.
Come sit down in my living room.
Talk about disappointment.
You can't zoom in on a brochure.
So you're telling me
Welcome to my living room, Link.
Now this is a, oh wow.
Okay, so.
Look around.
Look outside.
Oh, dude, you're living in a ski lodge.
Hey, yeah, it's snowing out.
Vaulted ceilings.
You got a big chandelier.
And then look at Netflix.
That is freakin' huge screen.
Look at the size of my television.
That's the biggest,
dude you didn't tell me you
had such a big television.
And I love how your mantelpiece
has the word Netflix burned in it.
Yeah, not a sponsor.
What ass hat would burn the word Netflix
into his mantelpiece
in his ski lodge home?
That's nice art.
Yeah, you like my art?
Yeah you got a loft up there.
Yeah.
Walk around.
That's me.
That's my body.
I'm on a couch.
You're sitting on a couch.
No I'm actually sitting behind the couch.
When I look down, it's the back.
Yeah, we can work that out later.
Okay.
And then, so, is the screen here,
but then it's just the rest of the,
I'm just in a lodge.
I mean it's like.
Yeah, but where would you be
if you were watching Netflix?
Where would you actually be?
Well, when I'm watching shows,
I tend to just watch the show.
I don't look around my room.
Yeah, don't look around.
Just watch the show.
Here take it off.
Before you're in you're gone.
All right.
I was trying to pick up the.
Take it off.
I don't wanna take it off.
I wanna be in your life.
Get outta my life.
I'm watchin' the screen saver in Netflix.
And it's pretty awesome.
Get outta my lodge, okay.
So I.
I don't think that's.
No, no, okay.
Something that you would wanna keep doing.
Not in 2019.
Not now.
Now I will say that I watched,
watched that show Mindhunter.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
I almost fell.
Uh, I watched a full episode of that in a.
See you can't even sit in a chair
in the real world any more.
Inside that.
And I gotta say that they're,
this is where the resolution
becomes frustrating
because if were to take the headset off
and watch on my television or on my phone,
the resolution would be
significantly higher.
Uh-huh.
But that's just a matter of time
before they get that straightened out.
But I do have,
I do have a few critiques,
Oculus people if you're watching.
Um, it's too heavy.
Because it's a standalone thing,
well first of all,
All of the weight is
in front of your eyes.
There's potentially this is a good thing
because it
Seems like they could
put weight on top of your head.
Well, yeah, so it feels like it might
limit your, there's a
two hour battery life
which is not a lot for somthin',
but you can just plug it in.
It's got a pretty long cable
so you can kinda stay tethered
if you want to have it be
powered as you're playing.
If you're doing that,
you might as well plug it into a PC.
Right, but then you're
it's defeating the whole
purpose of the thing.
But also the Rift has a lot less weight
because you're not using
all the computing power
is offloaded to an actual computer
where this is basically
like having a cell phone
in your face, you know.
So I feel like they could have
offloaded some of the weight
to like a different place.
Like you're saying,
like if it was a little,
I don't know, I'm sure
that I'm not telling ya
anything you didn't try probably.
But fix it for 'em.
Some battery or the CPU power
was offloaded to another spot on your head
to make it a more even thing,
like it was a little bit more helmet-y.
I think the playability
and the comfort-ability,
if that's a word, would have gone up.
Probably be safer if it was a helmet, too.
But, I, so I feel like, listen, again.
We sound like a couple of old guys
talking about something that's
been around for a long time
because that is exactly
what's happening right now.
Um, but, I think that it's just hit me
what this is going to turn into.
You know, I'm obviously.
What's the future?
I read and watched "Ready Player One"
so everybody knows that there's,
what that whole dystopian
future looks like
and people are living their lives in VR.
You definitely begin to understand how,
when they work out the
ergonomics of this thing,
and they get the physicality right.
Mmhmm.
And they continue to enhance
the haptic quality of this,
it gets to a place where you
could definitely get lost
in this world.
Now one of the things I didn't show you
is that this thing,
the way that this thing works,
is there's four cameras in it, see.
That's, I was wondering
if those were cameras.
So, so when you're just
walking around with this thing,
it replicates your world.
I mean I could just walk
around with this thing on.
Really?
But it's in black and white
kind of grainy
representation of the world.
So I could sit here and see you
and everything is exactly
where it needs to be
based on these four cameras.
Yeah.
So, the moment that they
get to a place where
you don't look like an ass
hat wearing this thing.
I don't know when that' gonna happen.
But if they're able
I mean they might as well
just go all the way and put
a crack in the middle of it.
So, again, I believe
that this is necessarily
going to require some
offloading of the CPU
and the battery power somewhere else.
We're not gonna get to a place,
unless technology changes significantly,
where battery power and CPU power
capable of creating the
types of graphic experiences
that would replicate actual reality
can be housed in a very small space
the size of glasses.
I mean, maybe eventually,
but there's limitations to computing
that are like that have
to do with physics.
You can't just keep getting smaller
and smaller and smaller.
They're already getting close
to reaching end of Moore's law,
which is how small they
can make a processor.
So given that there's some limitations
that they're gonna run up on,
we're probably gonna get to a place
where you're offloading the
CPU and the battery power
into some other part of your body,
where it's like on your
shoulders or your back.
Or in your mouth.
Or just, yeah, just like a Snickers bar.
I don't know why you'd
put it in your mouth.
Like a mouth guard.
Um, but the other thing that's happening,
in fact just today when I
was looking up some stuff
about the latest in VR technology,
there's a company that had is developed
this second skin that is
like it's gonna represent
a true touch-like experience
where they can make a,
they'll be able to soon make
a glove out the second skin
that some Swiss company
or somebody developed
where when you touch something,
it will give you feedback
that feels exactly like touch,
sort of like the haptic love dream
that we've always had.
Now,
So when I grab that black ball.
You'll feel it.
Or firearm, yeah, you can
use the haptic response.
Well and a thing that they've
actually already rolled out.
They haven't rolled it out
for everyone on the Quest,
but they just introduced it recently,
but they're rolling it out next year,
is hand tracking,
so you can set the controllers down
and you can play games
with just your hands
and it's using the four
cameras to track your hands.
Apparently, that's coming.
Wow.
So you combine really
awesome hand tracking
with really awesome haptics.
You get the situation so that
you basically all you need on your face
is the visual interface.
That's all you need.
So if we could get to a place
where it kind of looks like sunglasses.
Mmhmm.
And then you got other stuff
Tony Stark it.
On your back or whatever.
At that point,
You can operate on people.
You're getting to a place where
switching between AR and VR
becomes this just like effortless thing,
so the AR, the augmented reality,
where you're gonna be able
to be given information
about everything that you're seeing,
to have your experience enhanced.
RoboCop.
That just feels like,
I mean that's already
happening some places.
People use their phones or whatever,
but that's gonna be something
that everyone who has one of
these contraptions will have
and then the moment you
start kind of getting annoyed
with the real world,
you'll voice activate to go into VR
and you'll be, and it'll be so comfortable
that you will literally
be able to get lost in it
'cause you won't be
stopping to think about,
oh, my face hurts,
which is what happens with this thing.
Ah, I gotta adjust the,
it's on the back of my head.
When that goes away
and you're not worried
about battery power.
You can do this for long periods of time.
It's gonna change society
very significantly.
Everywhere you go will be
like a tourist attraction
'cause there'll be a
filter that'll turn off
all the ads, which will
inevitably be on everything.
Oh, this microphone.
You can buy it now and
it'll be delivered tonight
and here's the specs on it.
And this table, well you can
buy a table just like this
from Target, you know.
You block all of that stuff.
And then you turn on
fun facts and augmented.
Yeah.
Talking heads.
What was the name of that show?
Where they introduced
that pop-up TV thing.
Uh.
The very first show to do that
where it's like if you watch,
oh watching something like VH1.
I think it's called.
Pop-up Video.
Pop-up video.
Pop-up video, pop-up life.
Which is the way that video
games work, currently,
where there's like a user
name above somebody's head
and details about them.
We will get to a place
where that's happening
with people that you're
just interacting with.
And then, I don't know,
it's just the potential,
I'm not saying anything
that a thousand science fiction books
haven't already written about,
But now you've experience it.
Because I have understood it personally
and experienced it,
it hit me like whoa, okay.
This could be problematic for society.
Like this is something
that we're going to have to
address.
I mean just think about it.
Like you know, we're
already, we're already in.
Some societies are moving to a place
where like kids are
you know like teenagers
and young adults are not,
they're not dating.
They're not having sex.
You've got populations
where they're not replacing themselves.
And of course we've got a population issue
but ultimately you want,
well you want our species to be active
in replacing itself.
Right.
And what this is going to do,
is when the haptics get good enough,
if you know what I mean,
you're not going to need a
partner for sexual gratification.
That is something that
is going to be happening
in these headsets.
And that is going to change
society significantly
and it's something that we
need to be thinking about.
Well, yeah, you just
made me think about it.
I'm pretty distracted.
I'm just saying, that's gonna happen, man.
The way that experiences can be replicated
and the second skin and all
this stuff that's coming.
Coming is probably not
the best word to use.
That's on it's way.
Well I mean every technology
has been exploited
for either is pornography
and military, right?
Pornography in military, explain.
Well, I'm just sayin' that you got,
that's how, that's how
things have developed.
You talk about, just.
Oh, oh.
Think about space travel.
These technologies will be exploited.
Exploited first because that's where,
that's where either the money is,
like all this money funneled into military
is how like, okay, VR is gonna be advanced
because for militaristic purposes
and then it's
Yes.
Gonna be co-opted for
pornographic purposes.
Right.
But then it's gonna make its
way into mainstream society.
I completely agree with you.
What I'm specifically saying is that,
and the way that phones and cell phone use
has already contributed to
people being kind of isolated
in one sense.
Very connected, but also
lonely and isolated.
Unhappy.
The moment you can replicate
the most intimate human
experiences with technology,
is the moment in which those
human intimate experiences
will be replaced with technology.
And so that's all I'm saying.
Then there'll be a movement of.
There'll be a, there'll be
a retro realness movement
where it's like, you know,
the silver lining is it's an opportunity
to draw into sharp focus
what really matters.
You know, just to have a great experience,
be that pleasurable or
a learning experience
or um, just something unforgettable,
like an amazing hike through VR
or something like that.
There's gonna be an entire movement
of yes but we've forgotten,
you can be made to feel really good,
but there's something you
can't match the reward
of vulnerability with another person
Yeah, but.
And the dance of that.
But we'll be making those arguments
towards young people who
don't wanna hear 'em.
And but the other
Who don't.
But the other
Tell it to my, tell it
to my relational bot.
The other purpose is to
To be vulnerable to me.
The other alarming thing
that I think this represents
is that because the experiences by design,
by design are to your liking, right?
Yeah.
They're designed to be
You're the center of the universe.
Catered to you?
That is not how life works.
That's the, that is the
summing up of the danger,
right there.
So if you
You become the center of the universe.
If you are constantly in this world
in which everything is catered to you
and so when you have
your experiences in this,
however intimate those
experiences might be.
You'll never leave it.
Everything is exactly
the way that you want it.
The person's behaving exactly
the way that you want,
doing exactly what you want.
Your wish is my command.
You are basically a slave
is what would be in here.
Now you're trying to take that experience
and map it onto an actual
interaction with another human
that has its own interests
and does not care about your interests
the way that you do.
We have to think about this, from a,
and I, listen, I'm just a guy
who makes internet videos.
But, and I'm sure people are
already talking about this,
but it's just hit me.
Don't sell yourself short.
You're also an impulse buyer.
Just having worn this thing
and owned it for like a month,
the potential it's like I've
got this very scary thing.
Now, thankfully.
And you're hooking it up to your children.
Well you know what to speak to that.
Interestingly, and I think
I just got lucky with this.
So our kids are Locke is just busy.
He's busy with school and basketball.
He hasn't asked me to play on this thing.
Probably like once in the past month
after his initial interaction.
And Shepherd has asked
me a few more times,
because he's younger.
He's got more time.
He uses screens more often.
But because I've kinda got it in the room,
and I've got it kind of sealed away,
they can't just go get
it whenever they want to.
The amount of actual time
that they spend in this
is very minimal.
What about you, though?
I got, you know.
You're too busy?
I had that weekend.
And it was kind of a special weekend
because we didn't have
anything else going on.
I wasn't there.
And then.
I was in the great outdoors.
A few weeks have passed since that point
and I'd say.
You're over it.
I'm not over it.
Every time I get in it,
I'm like, man this is so cool.
I gotta get more games
and I've gotten a couple of more games,
but I am, there's like a cool puzzle game
which reminded me of the escape room.
It's basically you're in
an escape room situation
but you're in awesome,
you're like in an abandoned
like nuclear facility
and you're walking all around
and you're like, you're
playing with things
and trying to unlock codes and stuff.
Very similar to like an
escape room in Florida,
but better because you're
In your underwear.
But I actually, but no,
thankfully I don't have
an addictive personality
when it comes to stuff like this
and I don't think my kids do
so but it's just hitting me
that if I wasn't so busy,
if I didn't have so many
other things to distract me,
you could just sit in this thing all day.
Mmhmm.
It's gonna happen.
It's probably already happening.
Can I borrow it?
Uh, you can rent it.
You can lease it.
I gotta pay this thing off.
Is this your wreck, baby, wreck, baby
one two three four,
check, baby, check, baby, wreck it.
You know I have another wreck,
but I'm gonna go, I'll
save that for later.
Yes, this is my wreck.
Oh you can wreck it.
If you want to
After all that danger.
Again, this is not a sponsor.
Uh, we haven't, maybe we'll
work that out in the future.
How much this thing cost?
Uh, I got the, there's 399,
399 for everything that you need.
It's console-ish price range.
Uh, and I gotta say for somebody
who's not an aficionado,
but who's just kind of like a
little bit familiar with it,
it was the doorway for me, man.
It was, it's the gateway into VR.
I highly recommend it.
And yeah, it's the wreck.
Get you one of these things.
Get lost in the world.
See the potential for the
doom of the human species.
It cost me 400 dollars less
to gain access to the
Trail of a Hundred Giants.
Yeah but you can't just be at home
getting ready to go to bed
and think, hmm, I'd like to go to Idaho.
I can.
Idaho, huh?
I can go to Idaho.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
I can go to any state you want.
Let us know how alarmed you are.
We'll talk at ya next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To the watch the previous episodes
of Ear Biscuits, click on
the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.